uh my name is alan glickenhaus i'm going
to be the host in this room this is the
api architecture track i'm
happy to be with you today despite
winning mega millions yesterday yes i am
now four dollars richer
so uh i'll be uh be introducing the
speakers and and keeping things on
schedule here so the first speaker wins
the creative award for uh best title for
the the uh session uh sherlock holmes in
the cryptic case of api security what
what's going on here
with breaking news there has been a data
security breach at the popular investing
site robin hood more than seven million
experian application programming
interface on a student loan vendor's
website allowing any user to look up the
credit score of hundreds of millions of
americans by supplying simple
information and this api required no
authentication whatsoever while it's
still a breach involving the networking
site linkedin and this network was
reportedly investigating a data breach
involving up to 100 million customers 30
million people who applied for t-mobile
credit was stolen
platform twitch says the malicious third
party is behind a massive data breach of
the website feeling private information
including names addresses and drivers
license numbers of californians who were
granted or denied a concealed weapons
permit between 2011 and 2021. microsoft
is announcing that it's found another
wave of attacks by the russian
intelligence service that is acting
silent
report says 2021 saw a record number of
cyber attacks of 68
140 million consumers were compromised
by hackers that are still unidentified
the data also contains addresses of
hundreds of defense sites and navy
missile maintenance units bombing ranges
there were also weapons storage
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen i ask
that you please remain your seats as
this has now been designated
an api crime scene
uh please try not to touch or
contaminate any of the evidence you
might come across as we're going to be
moving very quickly to solve this case
my name is brenton house i'm the lead
detective on this case
i am also a ex-hacker developer
architect filmmaker and
digital evangelist at software ag now if
i look at my notes this is a group that
has volunteered to help me on this case
so let's get started
all right
in the next 15 minutes we're going to
solve a real world case
we're going to do that by applying three
principles
from sherlock holmes
so we're going to determine what
happened
and what could have been done
to prevent this now it's very important
that you remember these three principles
because there will be an exam later
so
the first principle is know your
resources
so sherlock holmes always knew
who and what was available to him as a
resource he had contacts in the police
department and pretty much
every other community
so
he took advantage of these resources and
he then leveraged them he could then
leverage the resources to build to find
who and what
could help him solve a crime each
resource might be different for each
situation but he had to use that
judgment
first we had know your resources second
we have know your situation
so sherlock holmes once said
i've trained myself to see things that
others overlook
sherlock holmes is known for his keen
sense of observation deduction
but in order to see
all the clues that were available to him
he had to hone those skills
so
he observed everything that was in his
world around him
he would then use this information to
make educated deductions based on
facts
data
and on patterns
we don't know a thing about each other i
don't know where we're meeting i don't
even know your name
i know you're an army doctor and you've
been embellished home from afghanistan
and you've got a brother who's worried
about you but you won't go to him for
help because you didn't approve of him
possibly because he's an alcoholic more
likely because he recently walked out on
his wife and i know that your therapist
thinks you're lymph psychosomatic quite
correctly on the frame
something to be going on do you think
the name's sherlock holmes and the
address is 221b baker street
afternoon
[Music]
okay so number one we had know your
resources two we had to know your
situation
and three
we have know your adversary
shulk holmes was always quick to learn
as much as possible about who he was up
against whether that was his arch
nemesis professor mariarty
or a common criminal he would study
their methods their tools their weapons
and their thought processes
so we have resources
situation
and adversary
it helps you remember acronym rsa then
go ahead and use that
all right before
we can take a look
at this case together i need everyone to
take the shock homes api detective
examination
now
i've been told that you are the best and
the brightest here in hub 2. so
i'm going to need you to speak your
answers clearly and loudly
so that everyone in hub 1 and 3 knows
that hub 2 rocks
all right
so
we have know your
okay i'm not sure the guy in the back of
the room could hear you guys let's try
it again know your
all right excellent next know your
great and
know your
okay great job you guys definitely live
up to your reputation
so let's take a look at this case
so the case that we're going to look at
today is the peloton api breach so in
january of 2021 a security researcher
discovered that an unauthenticated user
could access the peloton api and gain
access to user data for any user
including those that had their profile
marked as private
so the data that was exposed include
user ids instructor ids
workout information
geolocation
gender and more
so let's take a quick look at the
timeline
so first the vulnerability was
discovered
and it was reported to peloton
using the official peloton reporting
tool it was also they were given the
standard 90-day window to address the
issue before it would go public
next thing that happened was well
nothing peloton didn't respond publicly
or privately to
the researcher
next after a couple weeks api was
quietly
fixed and what i mean by that was now
the api was only accessible by those
that had
that were
authenticated
now
can anyone tell me really quickly
why that's not a fix
well
if the authentic if the app if the api
was required authentication
but not authorization policies so any
authenticated user could get into the
api but then still access data for any
other user
so again peloton was notified that their
fix didn't work
and the next was after the 90-day window
peloton
the press was notified press went to
peloton then peloton started responding
after a couple weeks the api was then
secured and
pelton
performed a public disclosure but by
that time
so much damage had been done
all right let's apply the three
principles that we just learned to this
case
first is know your resources
now there are a lot of api security
resources out there
there are great websites there are great
videos and youtube channels
but most importantly there is the owasp
top 10 list for api security
now the os top 10 list for api security
includes the top security
vulnerabilities for apis
this is going to be an essential toolkit
for your api security strategy
okay so let's take a look at the peloton
api case using this list
we can see
that they had broken object level
authorization broken user authentication
and
excessive data exposure at the very
least there may have been more
what that means simply is that they
didn't check who you were
they didn't check that you had
permissions to do what you wanted to do
and three they were sending way too much
information in peloton's case they were
sending personal information about
private users
next is know your situation
situational awareness with api security
is so important
you have to know what different types of
apis are out there but you also have to
know what apis you have what you're
consuming and what you're producing
you also need to know what your api
cyber security stats
strategy is now for most organizations
cyber security is a priority
however for a lot of cisos and cyber
security experts
api security is a gap for them case in
point the peloton api
so
when president biden decided that he was
going to bring a peloton bike into the
white house a group of cyber security
experts came together to look at the
situation
they analyzed the situation they looked
at the bike locked it down and assured
everyone that was completely safe
because this could not be hacked into
obviously their api security was a gap
because an unauthenticated user could go
in
and see the data for any user including
the president of the united states
all right i already said that there's a
lot of different types of apis we have
public external
open internal partner machine to machine
third-party apis composite and then your
beta and testing
now if we look at the peloton case you
can see that they were using a machine
machine api which is common with iot
devices and servers
but this type of api is often neglected
with api security when compared to the
other types of apis
but
these are not the only types of apis
that exist out there
there are also unknown apis such as
shadow apis and those are apis you try
and keep off the radar
zombie apis and those apis work great
but they haven't been updated in forever
and are missing critical security
patches
and frankenstein apis and those are apis
are hacked together they can be public
or internal but it's because they want
to access data from a system whose api
is either incomplete
or non-existent
so again if we look at the peloton case
we can see that it's kind of a form of
shadow api because they tried to keep
this api off the radar and undocumented
they also tried to use something which
is often called
security by obscurity which we know
doesn't work
all right now this is where the rubber
meets the road
[Music]
know your adversary
with api security is important that you
are able to get into the mind
of your adversary if you are going to
properly manage and secure your apis
i'm going to start with some blue team
defensive tools here
you have your api gateway now this
is so important
this is going to be the core and
foundation for your api security
everything is going to be based on this
you also have web application firewalls
or wafts these provide an additional
layer of protection using artificial
intelligence and machine learning
and you also have other api security
tools and these are typically dedicated
api security tools that can be used to
provide your shift left features which
help you at design time and development
and
your shield write features which protect
your api at runtime
now there are also red team
offensive tools now i'm not going to go
into details on a lot of these tools
but i will tell you this
you need to have an understanding of
what tools could be used
by someone to gain access to your apis
or just to discover vulnerabilities in
your apis it's worth your time to at
least know what these tools are and how
they work
so we looked at
knowing your resources knowing your
situation
and knowing your adversary but there's
also
a bonus
and that is
knowing where you're going
your api strategy
your api security strategy that you have
is very important you also need to know
where your gaps are not just in your
security but in your knowledge of api
security
keep
learning so continue your api cyber
security learning journey by
learning whatever you can but it's
important to know what you don't know
now i have a
api cybersecurity 101 series out on
youtube you can find that at youtube.com
forward slash brenton house but also
check out there's a api shorts youtube
channel and the software ag youtube
channel
there are also some great web resources
out there and i highly suggest you take
a look at api security.io so collin has
a fantastic newsletter and website that
really helps people stay up to date on
the changing world of api security
you can also check out my website at
brenton.house and also check out
softwareag.com to learn about the
products and the tools that can help you
securely manage your apis
all right
we learned a lot by looking at the
peloton case through the eyes of
sherlock holmes
we learned about knowing your resources
knowing your situation
knowing your adversary
but also about knowing what you know
now i appreciate everyone's help in
solving this case and i look forward to
solving our next case together if you
want to get in touch with me at all
you can feel free to connect with me on
linkedin
and send me a message there as well
and i believe we might have time for
um for any questions or we also have a
giveaway here so we'll take care of all
that uh i have a question to start with
so you mentioned um
the gap between api security and uh you
know traditional security
what kind of organizational structure do
you think works best to close that gap
so
there's the the term api is a product
and api first that
are used often
it it starts with a mindset change
at an organization
so realizing that apis aren't something
that you tack on to a product to
allow access to something that it needs
to be treated as a product not just in
your budget and your resources but also
your people that are going to be working
on it how you market it how you document
it and everything to realize that your
api is a product that people are going
to be consuming and if they have a poor
experience that can reflect poorly on
your other products as well
so return to questions
one of the better uh animated
presentations i've ever seen for sure
it's still there so no questions
they're they're giving away raffle
tickets for the cooler here
nobody has a question
we're all good
all right we're around to the raffle all
right
all right thanks thank you
[Music]